I've officially lived to see a movie
starring only one of the Olsen twins why
is this movie called Beasley I just
watched it I don't really understand
apparently his appearance is beastly
it's just an odd title I don't what are
you seeing Jeanette I'm seeing beastly
Oh
beastly yes so anyway this movie stars
Alex Pettyfer who is just like just in I
am Number Four and Vanessa Hudgens Neil
Patrick Harris and mary-kate Olsen just
her
I believe I mean they could have I guess
which now Ashley every once in a while I
don't know some extreme Olsen fans like
I can tell they're doing it again so
this film tells the story of a pretty
boy who's very obsessed with himself
incredibly rude just ultimate jock d-bag
to the point of shocking extremes and he
is cursed by mary-kate Olsen to look
incredibly disfigured and have all these
strange tattoo markings and cuts and
stuff on his face and the only way he
can go back to his normal self is if he
gets someone to fall in love with him
within a year if he doesn't he remains
that way forever so here's the deal the
meat of this movie is Vanessa Hudgens
Alex Pettyfer being together in a house
and having to live with each other and
get to know each other that is the meat
of this movie we have a pretty boy who
kind of has a little thing for Vanessa
Hudgens and she might also he is then
cursed goes into exile lives in this
house occluded from everyone saves
Vanessa Hudgens from a mugging then her
father has to have Vanessa Hudgens move
in with him because she's in danger of
being killed from the other mugger who
got away
who has threatened to kill her this is
my biggest problem for this movie it is
so obvious that the filmmakers and the
script writers wanted to tell this story
of this very ugly man who finds
possibility of love and she's forced to
stay there so she has to live with him
that's the story they want to tell they
want to tell that story that love can
bloom even with some guy is incredibly
disfigured and all that stuff and that
that doesn't mean anything my problem
with this movie is the setup to get to
that it's exactly that a set of
everything to get to that is so out of
this world never gonna happen
the first 20 minutes this movie are
absolutely excruciating ly awful to the
point where I was like oh my gosh please
tell me the rest of the movie it's not
gonna be like this it's just so fake the
way everything just falls into place
perfectly for these two characters to
suddenly be in this place together but
as soon as the two characters start to
get to know each other and they start to
have feelings bloom then the movie got a
little bit better because for one thing
the actors have really good chemistry
they work really well together
and the film has a good message not to
look at the superficial things of the
outside of somebody and try to see the
inside you know the beauty of someone's
inner person from that point on the
movie gets a lot better it's just that
that first beginning is so fake and
dumped and the film is filled with so
many cheesy parts that just you're like
oh my gosh this is just so so cheesy to
the point of like wow there's a lot of
cliches like the girl she falls asleep
right before he says something very
important and for some reason she has
the magical powers of being able to stay
asleep while he then lifts her up
carries her down the stairs
puts her in bed tucks her in and the
whole time she's like I mean that's
dangerous if you're a girl and you sleep
that well you better get one of those
rape whistle things because that is
dangerous Alex Pettyfer I think he's a
talented actor I think that he has a
future there's good stuff and Neil
Patrick Harris his character is really
funny I really thought he was funny he
plays a blind tutor who tutors him you
know I can't see him so you know it
works out the survey's about to get a
little personal one of the reasons that
this movie struck a little bit of a
chord with me was because when I was in
middle school I wasn't exactly mr.
popularity
I've lost a lot of weight since then and
I wasn't exactly the most popular guy so
I know what it's like for someone to
feel like they're an outcast and feel
like they're not accepted and to wonder
where they fit in I know what that feels
like and so I was able to relate to this
character a lot and I appreciated the
story of him being able to find someone
who's able to look past that that's a
sweet story you know it has the fella is
a good message it has a good intention
there's just so much easy you know what
I mean so because of like the 20 minute
opening that was just awful and the
overall cheesiness of it I can't fully
recommend this film I'm going to give it
two and a half out of four stars however
we have some talented actors here we
have some sweet things in regard to the
story it's just that it's just so so
corny
Oh
beastly yeah
Oh beastly yes so I'm going to give so
because the film so because of them
mainly speak